for the last two years of my life I've
been involved in a project that has
taken up almost every weekend every
vacation that we've been on and this is
something I vowed I would never do again
but I yes Howard Stern has written a new
book and Robin I swear to you it was
torture I know it was torture you would
tell me how tortured you were I didn't
know it about and I will now reveal the
new cover to you very nice picture that
is me looking pensive as an author is a
serious author what happened was I never
wanted to write another book and then I
and over the years I've been pitched by
a lot of publishing yeah that's what I'm
saying you've turned down a lot of
offers because the success of the other
two books the other two books are for
remember we're crazy like they sold out
in five minutes
it comes out officially May 14th so you
can pre-order right now pre-order right
now and therefore you would have the
perfect Father's Day gift because that
made sense to me because we know a lot
of dads like me but I predict the wives
will like this book really because this
is about my evolution and this is about
my interviews and this is a book of this
is what started out I was gonna put out
a book of my favorite interviews that
I've done then I said I can't just put
out a book of interviews I've got to now
comment on them and tell you why these
were good then I said well now I've got
to talk about that we move from series
like Simoneaux so I started talking
about the process and I started talking
about my life and some of the things
that have happened I really think this
is the capper to my career after this
like you're not writing another book now
I can tell you for sure my excitement is
that for 20 years I said I wouldn't
write a book yeah and even my wife said
you know I thought you bad you would
never write again with you know your
summers and I said I mean evitable it
happens I really thought I had it
figured
that I wouldn't have to give up a summer
but it's easy one right this is what I
love about it it's the summer everyone
is already saying Robin within ten
minutes it's the summary